this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armories Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history this
week we're showing Jonathan just a few
of the weapons from the beta of the
upcoming Arena shooter X defiant oh this
is this is like they know me and they
don't want me to be happy to be fair
I've seen worse I've literally seen
worse on YouTube recently You Know Who
You Are
let us know other games or guns you'd
like to see Jonathan break down in the
comment section below and if you enjoyed
this kind of content let us know by
liking the video right over to Jonathan
foreign
can we have an M4 and he says we have an
M4 at home this is our M4 at home it's
not far off is it or at least you'd
think not but uh the Finish is too too
black really for a usgi rifle this is
actually a quote-unquote British M4A1
and it isn't just to show it it's an
interesting artifact in its own right of
the weird chapter in the in the British
Firearms industry but I've I'm waving it
around mainly because of this this bit
of barrel here so the M4 and the M4A1
have a 14 and a half inch barrel the
Barrel in the game appears to be either
16 inches or based on the civilian
16-inch Barrel I think the barrel is too
long the other aspect are the reloads so
I should say the model overall and the
texturing and the wear that all looks
great lighting all looks good sound
absolutely fine case ejection looks good
it's one of my pet peeves as you know
but what doesn't look right to me all
the reloads not the style of reload with
Team magazines in the hand there to swap
over it's the insertion of the magazine
itself so on an AR Mac you have the the
cut out there that's what that's what
this magazine cat latches into for those
of you who don't know quite a simple
mechanism really and we see the magazine
go in
and it stops about there
at least that's what I'm saying it stops
well before the latch would actually
engage maybe about here it's a bit
further in than that so the magazine in
the game is not going far enough in to
stay in and if you then presented the
rifle to to start shooting it would just
drop out immediately
okay Chris Vector fascinating firearm
with a an Innovative bolt system
um we're very keen to get our hands on
one fingers crossed the one in the game
now because we because we don't have one
um I can't really do nerdy comparison
I've seen the the gun builder here with
Myriad versions of butt stocks and hand
guards barrel lengths muzzle devices
sites the usual story I think all of
that's sort of legit that you know if
you could get it you could fit it the
way the gun in the game seems fine it
doesn't really differentiate itself
particularly from other guns but I think
I think the The Recoil mitigation of the
of the vector is a little hard to
represent unless you have it just have
zero recall I don't know how it handles
in the game it's consistent the way the
way it's depicted is consistent with
reality now when I I fired one of these
10 years ago which is quite depressing
the thing that really impressed me about
it was the two round burst setting
because they're so fast and the system
kicks in so well and the ergonomics of
the thing seemed to work factor into
that as well a suppressor as well to
help mitigate recoil and add a bit of
weight to the muzzle two round bursts
bang on target I'd have liked to have
seen that in the footage I don't know if
the game replicates it but for me that
would be the sort of USP unique selling
point not Universal service pistol of
having this gun in the game
foreign
[Music]
rigged grips and bits of tape and going
back to Old Call of Duty games things
like wrapping the Slinger in right
around the gun there's a bit of string
so there's a bit of bungee cord on the
back of this wrapped around through the
sling Loop I'm guessing that's meant to
be retaining something on the other side
or I don't know I don't know what that's
there for but then the optional grips
leather wrapped foregrip why what's the
point of that I mean obviously in this
it tweaks your stats slightly but the
Tactical grip which is identical to the
normal grip but with some blue tape on
it bewildered by those those options now
in furnace to the developers here the
P90 unless you cut off this molded in
foregrip and try to replace it with
something your options are limited so
they've tried to be faithful to the gun
design great recent Call of Duty games
as much as I enjoy them have drifted
quite drastically away from the real
guns so nice to see them seemingly
representing the guns very accurately I
can't see any major issues oh yes I can
but I think it's deliberate so we seem
to have actually cut away one side of
the clam shell see the seam here just
like the Airsoft version this is a
clamshell design creating the foregrip
and they have actually cut away leaving
the screw exposed one side of the grip
so I guess the idea is the idea here
that this is a broken old P90 and your
rip options are bodges to replace that I
may have reacted a little too strongly
to to the concept if so that's a
somewhat creative way to get around the
idea that we need to be able to upgrade
the gun by effectively downgrading it to
make it really rubbish to hold by
missing half its grip and then different
varying and sophistication ways of
getting a path grip watch back on so
first climbing a lot in possibly forever
that wrapping random stuff around your
gun might actually have an in-game
justification
the Remington m870 we've seen this many
times lots of sort of tactical upgrades
for this one but also downgrades again
so we've got we had a broken P90 and now
we have a broken 870 unless that's
deliberately cut away so you might
possibly cut away a trigger guard to fit
in a thick Mitten type gloves classic
Arctic trigger guard setup I've never
seen that done to a shotgun ever and
that doesn't look enough of a gap to
actually function as a an Arctic trigger
guard so I think it's meant to just be
broken that's a highly improbable way
for a for a gun to break we've got a
contradiction almost of relatively
pretty Modern Hardware I don't know if
this is near future or not I'm guessing
it is and then wear and damage like even
the M4 was significantly worn and old
looking one option here a folding
vertical grip attached to a picatinny
rail pump grip makes my brain itch
slightly don't like that but that's just
an option you know give people choice
and they will make choice
foreign
firearming games is the rpk in either
guys actually the original rpk or the
rpk
74 which is what this is this is an
actual Russian rpk 74 the the wooden
furniture well wooden furniture and what
should be a polymer pistol grip are
damaged so another bit of damage here
again I don't know how you would do that
damage but the way it's been done is
quite realistic with the sort of fibers
of the wood visible but it's a very
unlikely spot I think for this weapon to
end up getting damaged and the pistol
grip again I don't know if if a polymer
pistol grip gets cracked and these
things are very hard to crack they would
tend to just crack and just come off not
so much lose a chunk off the back and
the attempts to wrap tape around it
whilst you would want to do that to
prevent any sharp bits especially tiny
little glass fibers from the
reinforcement getting into the heel of
your hand that seems like an inadequate
amount of taping I am wondering if the
yeah the curvature on the mag is wrong
the mag to me looks like a 762 40 round
mag whereas you can see from this 5.451
the way to spot curvature because
sometimes it's hard to tell when if you
don't have one to compare in the same
shot or nearby or handy as we're
fortunate to have is the angle of the
floor plate so if I hold that as it
would fit the the receiver you can see
the floor plate
is it
that sort of angle whereas the floor
plate on this steel magazine in front of
me is at a much steeper angle which
tells you if your eye can't detect it
otherwise that the curvature is much
greater so it's down as an rpk74 on the
face of it it isn't
foreign
MacMillan attack 15. handling wise can
you shoot a bolt action 50 cal rifle
accurately from the shoulder broadly no
I think if you're going to choose a 50
for an FPS that is suitable from the
shoulder with a massive muscles and B A
lot of practice well actually have to be
massive muscles a lot of it's technique
but you're going to get fatigued very
quickly then I'd go with the Barrett's
self-loading evens out the recoil
impulse muzzle brake on the end
um version of the attack 50 we saw that
didn't seem to have a break although
there was definitely one in the in the
menu anyway you definitely want the
muzzle break on there too even out to to
counteract some of that felt recoil but
because you don't have moving parts so
recording barrel and bolting them as in
the Barrett to as I say smooth out the
recoiler impulse you're really going to
feel it and you're gonna get tired and
you're gonna miss so much like an lmg
this thing really needs to be fired off
the bipod
[Music]
yeah
next up good old-fashioned akm this is
squarely in the akm bracket I can't see
anything glaringly wrong with it now the
the missing top cover is irking me we
see this a lot in post-apocalyptic
settings the implication here with all
these broken weapons is that times are
hard so of all the conflict zones I
haven't been to but I've seen photos and
footage from or sent to me missing top
covers aren't really a thing like if
you're missing the top color the thing
is probably in such a state that it's
basically unusable I'm sure someone some
out there has used one without the top
cover on it but it isn't hard if your
top cover is dented or damaged to panel
beat that sucker back into shape and get
it back on your gun this is relatively
straightforward Gunsmithing stuff and it
has a huge advantage of not allowing all
sorts of crud into your your weapon and
jamming it up so bigger issue with the
missing top cover is that it shows you
that the selector is in the wrong place
pretty certain that that safety and
selector lever is at the full up
position which it normally would block
seal off from somewhat from dirt and
liquid and stuff and then you push it
down to the first setting for automatic
and all the way to the bottom for
semi-automatic well this one is stuck up
so the weapon should not be functioning
at all the other thing about the top
cover being missing is that we can see
the hammer is in the fired off position
so it's it's it's down Hammer is down
against the back of the bolt against the
firing pin that weapon shouldn't fire
the whole point of the one not the whole
point but a large point of the bolt
carrier is to override the hammer and
[__] it ready to then fire when you
press the trigger and then the action
will [__] it again each time major part
of self-loading or an automatic weapon
and we don't see although we have the
bolt animated nicely coming back and
forth we don't get the hammer animated
foreign
at the risk of showing off
two acrs now uh this is as many acrs as
we have I've only picked up both because
one's black and one's tan and the
version in the game that I'm seeing here
is a mixture of both if we had a bit
more time I could swap some some parts
over and recreate roughly the right gun
both of ours are set up as 556 rifles
the gun in the game is in 6.8 so that's
six that's not 6.8 by 51 or 277 Fury
which is the new high pressure Sig rifle
round for the for the uh what
sustensibly the new US Army rifle the M7
or xm7 it's not that this is older this
is the 6.8 uh SPC round from a few years
back which is still around uh people are
still using it it's not particularly
common ballistically it seems like a
good compromise but realistically people
seem to have either stuck with 5.56 or
gone for something more powerful like
some 2 or this new 6.8 so 6.8 just
refers to the bullet diameter I suppose
in sort of in Universe if this is a sort
of austere environment in which weapons
and ammunition are hard to get then
running a rifle in six eight seems a bit
silly and if anything they should be
trying to find the 556 barrel and bolt
so that they can convert their rifle to
556. obviously uh being a modern modular
design originally the Magpul Masada this
thing is designed to have different
barrel lengths different Furniture can
be reconfigured even our two acrs which
are which are almost identical have two
different muzzle devices on them they're
not much different apart from that but
point is you can swap out basically
whatever you like which lends itself
very well to this kind of gun gunsmith
interface
oh this is this is like they know me and
they don't want me to be happy there
when there's butchered Mosin Nagant here
to be fair I've seen worse I've
literally seen worse on YouTube recently
you know who you are at least these
modifications look somewhat reversible
we do have sling wrapped pointlessly
around the weapons syndrome which I will
never understand more damage quite well
modeled damage again there's a loop a
sling around the front through the front
sling Loop that doesn't seem to connect
to the random mess of Sling at the back
I can hear drill instructors and
directing stuff the world over crying
out in agony seeing a sling fitted like
that and I'm not even served very very
excessive height over bore as well with
that um Riser optic thing and then a
massive like 20 Power Plus scope that's
that's parked on top of it right now I
don't have that much time behind Moses
but um I don't remember the clip being
able to eject itself with that much
Authority
um as far as I know it's just it's very
common system where when the clip they
pressed all around into the into the
magazine you can push the bolt forward
and the clip will be pushed out of the
way um some some rifles are designed
more specifically to help flick that out
with some Authority what they don't
generally do is make it eject vertically
out of the gun because the physics are
against it there so unless I'm missing
something that seems to be incorrect but
broadly correct in terms of how it
functions
another very tired looking gun here this
time it's an MP7 I'm always a little
skeptical in when I see mp7s in pop
culture settings as to where the heck
they found this thing because it's a
relatively exotic firearm fine uh
they've maybe proliferated of course the
other aspect is if this is set in the
United States then the select fire the
so-called machine gun variants are going
to be non-existent and because there is
no civilian MP7 variant the same applies
there as well but anyway they've got
hold of one and it looks broadly fine
major points to to these guys for not
going off-piste with the designs I keep
going on about Call of Duty deciding to
make their guns different for whatever
reason probably legal except
I think this is good evidence that it is
not in any way a strict legal
requirement to change the design of a
firearm because Ubisoft haven't so
that's good
foreign
16a4 appears to be correct including the
three round burst the three round bet
they seem to have bought the height of
the original height from 1982-ish of the
three round burst that you'll be able to
keep all those three shots on Target
because they're happening very rapidly
and they're automated the reality is not
that the reality is that your first
bullet will be in the center of the
Target and the next one in the burst
will be up and right and the next one
might well be off the target entirely it
isn't actually that ideal you have to
learn to control it just like you have
to learn to control automatic all it
does is prevent you from going cyclic
and emptying the magazine
let us know what you thought in the
comments as always now I would always
mention the uh the Royal armories where
I'm currently sitting up in Leeds that's
one of our museums we have one on the
south coast as well that does artillery
um and we're also in the Tower of London
so if you can at all visit us we welcome
you to do that if not we do have our own
YouTube channel featuring yours truly
and various social media channels as
always and you know do the like And
subscribe thing as well we'll see you
again next week